for me i actually wasn't afraid of the
needles until
i gave them to myself and then the
medication was extremely nauseating
so i'd get nauseous so when i started
getting nauseous after i was giving
myself my needles then i
then i got an aversion to it before that
i guess i don't know why
um maybe i'm brave but i wasn't i
remember getting vaccinated when i was a
kid and it didn't bug me i was like yeah
in both arms in this one three at once i
don't know when that was but uh
it did i didn't get an aversion until
the nausea started from the medication
but i can see how that could happen to
people nausea is such a
um biopsychosocial thing you know
and what i mean by that everything is
everything's biopsychosocial means we
have a biological component there's a
psychological component and there's the
social component of it
and nausea is particularly in in
medicine we have this term
supratentorial the tentorium is a
barrier in the brain that separates
the the anatomical structures of our
cortex which are the
like what we think is our rational
reasoning all that and the lower
structures which are emotion
and that sort of thing and and and and
and more um
not even emotional more like our
autonomic structures like breathing and
that stuff that happens
in the background and we say something
super tentorial when we're trying to say
that's psychologically driven nausea is
a great example when you
see the needle and you've associated it
with vomiting before like chemotherapy
people they just see the bag
and they get so nauseous yeah i see it
it it's and
we evolved that i mean it's important
protection mechanism it's a disgust
response and it keeps us safe from
poisons and so on and but boy it's hard
when you're a kid i mean i
i gotta say this like when i heard your
story i was like just outpouring of
compassion because i couldn't
imagine that's why i couldn't do
pediatrics just the suffering of
children
is beyond the pale like um yeah so
that you've come out this strong kind of
you know
intelligent articulate person who can
talk about issues and knows who you are
that's not the standard outcome right
yeah
it's a result of resiliency and finding
meaning and suffering and so on which
i'm sure
your dad could speak to better than i
can but you know kudos it's
not easy to do thank you
thank you i'm tougher now um and that
that needle fear definitely went away
as soon as i stopped giving myself the
medication i was like um
i could poke myself like i i did too
just out of curiosity which is [ __ ] up
but like
i was like ah it's gone it's gone as
soon as i didn't like
anyway anyway um
yeah yeah but it wasn't fun it does make
me extremely skeptical about anything
medical because as soon as i did go
why is this happening to me and then
searched around a little bit i was like
oh
well okay i could have changed things
and i would have stopped this
that's not fun like that made me so
angry for like i'm still angry
but i was i was angry enough that i was
getting panic attacks when i went into
hospitals
which never like that never happened i
was always i was always okay
and then as soon as diet reversed all my
symptoms and all my symptoms went away
and i went off all of my medications
i had a phobia of hospitals for about i
had a phobia of hospitals until
i had to bring my dad to hospitals and i
had to force myself to go into the
hospital
to go with him and then i was having
panic attacks in those hospitals
and eventually i desensitized myself and
now the panic attacks are gone
but but yeah it's been it's been a wild
ride
it's been a very wild ride nothing that
you said is
is unusual or
i mean it all makes sense you know i i
one of the earliest memories i have is
of being tied down by a bunch of nurses
so that they could
give me vaccines and check my blood
pressure
and the feeling i remember this my mom
was in the room it was at her hospital
because she
my both my parents are doctors yeah so
they they took me to their own hospital
tie me down
uh the thing's squeezing on me i'm
screaming and punching and
and nurses are having to like restrain
me because i'm violent
right and now so when i first started
training as a
as a physician and i would enter a
hospital i would have this like
surge of like weird adrenaline i
couldn't figure it out and anytime
anyone checks my blood pressure that
isn't me my blood
pressure is elevated and when i check it
it's it's low
and i realize it's this conditioning you
know it it
it really is and we forget that children
are conditioned
it's how we evolved we we incorporate
this stuff and still we
until we make it conscious until we see
it or desensitize it like you did by
going in the hospital
facing the fear this is why all this
stuff about ptsd i need to avoid
triggers no you need to face
with help don't do it alone it's hard
but you
you that's why we don't have safe we
don't make safe spaces we don't ban
words we don't
uh coddle children we we
make them face this stuff with help and
love
period that's what i think we ought to
be doing with love
yeah i agree which is why the coercion
doesn't work
when i um when when i first started
having those
like i went it surprised me right i went
to a hospital i had a panic attack and i
was like
what because there wasn't any it was
like a physical there wasn't even a lot
of mental there
right i just had this physical response
and i talked to my dad and my dad said
that's a completely reasonable response
given what happened to you yeah
but you need to desensitize yourself
because you're probably going to need to
end up you know you're probably going to
need a hospital at some point which was
like way sooner for other people than i
wanted it to be
but uh it's definitely interesting
that was very interesting you're smart
uh no i just talked i'm still super no
no you're smart i'm still very skeptical
but but those are excellent explanations
you should be skeptical if one person
can convince you in a conversation about
something then you're probably not
skeptical enough you need to continue to
get in as much data as you can and then
you have to feel into it too and go okay
well my intuition is one thing often our
intuition is wrong but what is it
telling me about me
that is resisting and how how can i then
recognize the bias and still understand
how to make a good decision for me
and the good decision may still be well
you don't want to get vaccinated fine
then maybe that's a good decision for
you especially given your risks and so
on you know
um are you on any sort of and you don't
have to answer this because it's a
medical question but are you on any
immuno-suppressing
medications that would put you at risk
for infection
no but i i was until i was 23. i
literally put all of my
symptoms into remission i have no
arthritis and
this is actually really exciting i could
never
put my hands on the ground with my wrist
flat
like so i used to get off the ground
when i was a kid like this
because of the arthritis in my wrist
yeah i did my first push-up
in my entire life with my wrists like
this
yesterday i could do that wow for the
first time in my entire life
yeah that's really i almost cried like i
really almost cried i said it it is
emotional
it's emotional and and the thing is you
know and again i think about your story
and and
the kind of suffering you know when i
saw the interview you did with your
um with your dad the the long one
where you were talking about his
hospitalizations and the path you went
through i mean that was so
affecting not just because of your dad
who you know i've admired and
his struggle is is you've documented it
and
it was looking at you and going wow
she's been through
hell on all these sides and yet isn't
insane yet i mean she's close to him on
video
on video yeah my husband today sent me
a meme and it's this duck and it's just
paddling
and they're on a waterfall and he's like
this is you
so on video but thank you
but but you have to accept that listen
you have to accept that the thing is
you're you're the type of patient that
many of us doctors
are terrified of because you you've been
through all this
so you have all this collected trauma
you have a complex medical condition
that we don't fully understand
but we think we do but we want to feel
like we do so we reduce it to receptors
and pills and so on
but we've not seen the full
biopsychosocial thing because it's
complicated and we don't get paid for
that we don't have the time for that
we're
hurting ourselves be you know because
we're suffering in a system that doesn't
value connection it values throughput
and
for that reason you're a challenge to us
that
hurts us morally because we want to help
you when we know we can't and so we
don't have the tools resources and
autonomy to do